[Music]
billy john marcos here
hello hello how are you sorry i'm not in
in the um studio but i see you've taken
much yeah it's it's very nice do people
go on the floor normally when you're
here
we usually have a little uh a couch by
the side there or would would it be
accurate to call it a bonkett
i would call it a sofa yeah sopha just
on the side there for i guess but since
billy's away
you've uh you've taken it and it's a
lovely chair billy's in your city and
you're in billy city so amazing oh yeah
what are you doing there
um basically hanging out and watching
shows and
really really sweating a lot and yeah
it's rough yeah
it's really hot here just now were you
here
later yeah what are you doing in los
angeles oh i'm doing some uh stand-up
comedy taking some meetings
uh
very like
did they love you have you ever
do they think you're hot
i
like uh yeah yeah i just did not like
sexy sure but i think that helps if they
think that as well yeah billy and i talk
about this thing all the time the
difference between a a kind of casting
audition meeting thing in
the united states as opposed to britain
is
in the united states everyone loves you
so you'll get out of the meeting and
you'll call your agent
and say yeah it went pretty well uh i
look forward to hearing what they say
and your agent says all right girl cool
i'll find out and then they'll come back
and say they loved you they they think
you are fantastic you're like oh great
yeah you didn't get the part sure
whereas in britain it's more along the
lines of
there's a real kind of blunt
transparency of
you know they went they went in a
different direction or it wasn't wasn't
really for them or they're just much
more frank and bru i'm not sure which
one i prefer at this point bills
yeah i don't know because it's nice when
people say they like you even if they
don't it's just nice to hear that
sometimes
yeah you get used to this
like
slightly um
to be honest slightly disingenuous kind
of vibe in the business that everyone
loves you because they can't all love
you you know
sure we're all we're both bullshitting
i'm taking a lot of these where they say
you know you're what are your movie
ideas your tv ideas and you know i got i
got one line and i just go oh it's about
family and they go interesting i can't
wait to see that pitch and i go back
home and go oh [ __ ] right gotta
flush this out that's supposedly the
vindies of the recent um
fast and the furious film which i've not
seen i've only i only saw the first fast
and the furious film i'm not a big
you're way behind i'm not i'm 26 now i'm
not yeah i'm not a big car person
doesn't do anything for me but
supposedly in the recent fast and the
furious film
the whole thing is about family
we've got to protect the family
it's all about does he does it does he
protect them by going faster i don't it
goes fast supposedly they dr i don't
know if this is true but i think they
drive a car so fast that it goes into
outer space i think one of the films i
think so i mean billy loves outer space
but driving a car into outer space
surely the windows would crack surely if
somebody asked me if i was in a meeting
um and they said to me what is your
pitch for a movie i'd say how about a
car that goes so fast it goes back to
the future
oh brilliant what a brilliant name for a
friend that you could that could be the
title of the film as well billy it could
be to the future to the future just in a
really fast car that's great i see
that's opening there's a musical over
here now as well is it
jean marco is that how you pronounce
your name that's perfect
thank you very much tell me about new
york city
oh i was i've been there for a while i
uh i grew up in maryland went up there a
lot as a kid i lived in harlem for a
long time oh nice harlem
which uh you know harlem it's a it's
it's a historically black neighborhood i
lived across the new whole foods on
malcolm x boulevard which is what he
would have wanted i'm sure
and uh
i was there for a good good eight years
and now i live on the lower east side
well i lived in the lower east side for
a little bit i live just near the
williamsburg bridge i'm right by there
oh really what were the cross streets oh
my goodness it was like over 10 years
ago um
i don't know but when i when i would
come out of my flat
if i turned directly right it was like
the walkway to the williams de lancie
yeah delancey that's exactly where i was
we might
on the board of little italy right sure
i'm at clinton in rivington which is
right by the delancey stop so delancey
was definitely the main street there and
then i don't know the cross street but
god i love new york city billy's heard
this story a million times but one of my
favorite ever
live music moments was i was doing this
film
um and we finished kind of late or at
least it felt late because it was winter
time in new york and it gets dark at
like four o'clock you know yeah and it
got dropped off a few blocks away from
my house because i wanted to walk
because i love walking in new york and
it's freezing like bitterly cold and i
was not wearing appropriate clothing and
i walked past this very small very
packed bar
and i thought i'll jump in here
warm up have a quick kind of night cap
and then head home but i was like why is
this bar so full and the bar was
completely full because there was a guy
on stage on this tiny little stage
playing this tiny little miniature piano
and i couldn't leave like i was gonna go
and have one drink i ended up having two
or three met the guy afterwards he's
called chris garneau an amazing
singer-songwriter but playing on a tiny
miniature piano about this big and he
has this like real high falsetto voice
billy and billy's wife absolutely loved
him when i introduced and yeah and that
was just one of the moments you know
those beautiful moments in new york
you're walking you kind of get slightly
lost suddenly you turn a corner and
you're like oh that looks interesting
and you go in and uh-huh uh-huh i love
it
new york's great oh yeah well give give
billy a recommendation of what you
should do tonight i guess go to
katz's deli
if you want like a nice jewish meal
like it's a reuben sandwich some matzo
ball soup where they'll treat you kind
of roughly they're a little gruff you
better know what you want when you get
to the front of that line they don't put
up with any kind of [ __ ]
that's a good new york fail yeah that
sounds good i'll maybe do that is that
on the lower east as well lori's side
yep it's not not too far from from where
we're at well i took my mom and dad
there when they came to stay with me
because it's almost from where i was i
seem to remember was it would you be
crossing that big delancey street and
it's kind of
yeah it's just a little bit a little bit
north of that delancey street yeah
couple blocks oh my god billy the
sandwiches are like this it's amazing
go do that go go to the comedy cellar
that's my home club you want to see some
stand up go check that out
but you won't be there so what's the
point i know i know they should just
shut it down while i'm here
so
they should actually and so tell us
about how how often do you play there
it depends how they're feeling about me
i mean it is it is pretty volatile as a
stand-up comedian you just give your
avails
and you hope the big celebrities are
that's the problem with stand up here in
l.a is you try to get the major clubs
here and the lineup is
movie stars all right so people gotta
there's got a long line dane cook's got
to be sick
for me to get out right at the laugh
factory they tell you they've got a spot
for you and you're ready to go and then
suddenly chris rock walks in to try
something out and they're like sorry
yeah okay that's how that happens to me
at the seller though chris rock was
running some stuff before his big tour
and sometimes they keep you there
they'll just extend the show make it a
two and a half hour show really but
sometimes you get bumped
and and that's just how it goes and
stand up now as someone representing the
stand-up comedian
sect and this might have been overly
done a little bit by now but how did you
feel about the the slap heard around the
world
i mean it's bad
i i haven't heard too many takes many
pro pro slap uh yeah good point yeah no
it's it's bad it was more just shocking
the lack of
i guess they assume it wouldn't happen
most comedy clubs don't have security
you just think the oscars would
but but
also who's going to stop smith from
going up on stage yeah yeah it's
definitely not a good look yeah uh
i
every comedian we deal with clubs where
there's just no security at all the
security is there to enforce the bill
being paid
not me being protected yeah yeah so i've
had i had one audience member after a
show this was not the comedy seller
which has pretty great security but it
was it's called lol
i keep naming it i should be careful but
uh
someone was mad at me and they were
really getting in my face and the
security guard instead of getting in
between them
shoved the check near his hand to make
sure that he signed for the bill before
he punched you
yeah yeah exactly so it happened and do
you remember specifically what the joke
or the subject was that got on their
nerves they were heckling i'm sure
something political
if you're this was like a
if you you've been to times square
this is the kind of show that they bark
at people they call barkers yelling at
people to come see the show so these are
people who did not know they were seeing
a comedy show that night these are
people who couldn't get tickets to
wicked
and are wasted and they just found out
their drinks cost 25 for a heineken
and i think i said something to him it's
not a uh i think something um
oh what's what's the actor uh he was a
firefighter he's a real firefighter
something about he looked like steve
buscemi on meth which already we're
starting with steve buscemi yeah and
then we're adding meth yeah this was a
rough look yeah and uh they were mad
about that
i didn't do it unsolicited though they
they were they were hectic they were
heckling oh for sure you have to shut
down a heckler right yeah it can be fun
if you have a heckler where like you
shut them down and then they stop that's
cool yeah that's ideal but sometimes you
have uh a lot of bachelorette parties
that's the most dangerous
a white woman in a plastic tiara that's
going to be the right friend
yeah and it's just like
if you ask them to be escorted out you
got to be you got to be as a comedian
you got to be cool you got to be kind of
funny take it all in stride the moment
you kick someone out you're a principal
you're authority you're supposed to be
making fun of authority
so
i i did a casino recently where where
there's a bachelorette party and
the code with the casino is you're
supposed to say
oh yeah you look like you could use some
water and that's the code for them to
come over there and take them out and no
one did anything so i was like they
really could use some water a couple
waters for this lady here and then
nothing happened
at the end they said oh well it looked
like you were handling them pretty well
and i was like well that's that's my job
right did you want me to
fall into a ball start crying and then
you go oh i think you need some help
so it's a tricky balance they rarely
kick people out of comedy clubs you
gotta really be pushing it
hey tom when you're running a business
it's difficult sometimes you try to make
everybody happy you're trying to make a
nice place for everyone who work and
it's not always easy take for instance
somebody keeps coming to work and they
absolutely stink
i mean what do you do i tell you what
you do you better talk to bambi yes with
bambi get access to your own dedicated
hr managers starting at just 99 per
month they're available by phone email
and real-time chat so onboarding and
terminations run smoothly team members
reach peak performance and your business
stays compliant with changing hr
regulations and with bambi's hr
autopilot your ultimate important hr
practices like setting policies training
feedback all that kind of stuff tom hr
managers can easily cost you 80 grand a
year is that right yeah but bambi starts
at 99
a month that's fantastic schedule your
free conversation today to see how much
bambi can take off your plate go to
bambi.com right now and type in onion
under podcast when you sign up it'll
really help the show spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e.com
bambi.com type onion bambi matches you
with your very own dedicated hr manager
that you can easily reach by phone chat
or email bambi's dedicated hr managers
will know your business and your
specific concerns hr issues can kill you
one complaint against your company can
turn your world upside down you spend
too much time dealing with hr when you
should be spending your time on making a
profit
now a word from our sponsor better help
hey dom you know sometimes you can get
stuck on a problem and you can't find
the solution because you're too busy
looking at the problem you're just gonna
you're spiraled um and then sometimes
you just need some help to get out of
that it can be tough to train your brain
to stay in
problem-solving mode when faced with a
challenging in your life but when you
learn how to find your own solution
there's no better feeling a therapist
can help you become a better problem
solver making it easier to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or how
small
and also as we know therapy can be a
little intimate you can feel a little
vulnerable going through the process but
the fantastic thing about better help is
it can all happen online so you don't
even need to have a face-to-face
conversation with a therapist if you
don't need to you can do it via phone
you can do it in your own way and you
know the intimate allows people to go
through therapy without feeling so
vulnerable about the experience yeah
exactly so if you're thinking about
doing therapy i would say better help is
a great option i agree because it's so
convenient it's accessible it's
affordable and it's entirely online when
you want to be a better problem solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
onion today to get 10 off your first
month that's better h e l p dot com
slash onion
it's strange right because as actors
you know billy and i have been exploring
doing a play for a couple of years now
and at some point hopefully in the not
too distant future we'll do that but as
actors if billy and i were on stage
together doing a play
and someone in the audience
even attempted to heckle sure it
wouldn't even be something that billy
and i would have to do someone working
for the theater would come over and say
please don't talk and if you talk
anymore you will be escorted out but in
a comedy club sometimes people think
they're part of the show more and more
and i think the problem is comedians
these days we really get our following
off posting clips and a lot of people's
clips because they might not want to
burn their material online will post
these
encounters with hecklers and they can be
fun but then everyone gets conditioned
to think oh that's what the show is so
people come to shows and they'll say hey
it's my you know it's my mom's 80th
birthday can you really roast her
make her cry
on this the day of her birthday
but i started i started i mean i'm a
theater kid originally so like
it's
it's always amazing when i think patti
lupone she's had a couple of moments
where she's
she she'll break out of the play to deal
with what's going on she yelled at
someone for taking pictures
and i think the the person ended up
being with the new york times and they
had been allowed to take pictures but no
one told me oh that's not good oh my
gosh paddy suffers no fools yeah uh yeah
i did i did uh i did a tv thing
with her and on the car
coming back from set one time it was a
little
money
minivan
and she started singing show songs it
was absolutely amazing
i was like i was asking the driver just
to drive around for a while and we could
just listen to that yeah
yeah what kind of play you're gonna do a
play
yeah we we're thinking about it um
i guess it's slightly under wraps
because we're still trying to figure it
out but billy is you know
billy shut your face billy is in the
center of the of the theater district in
the united states so he's he's kind of
you know doing a little bit of
groundwork for us and you know we're
talking to
different places here and different
places in
london it's weird i mean
i started out same as you and i'm sure
soon as billy started out doing plays
that was how i realized i really wanted
to be an actor was doing plays and
showing years of plays at school and
then outside of school and then at
college and
not only is it when it's when it's
cracking off my favorite medium to work
in but it is certainly
my friend's favorite way to watch me
work and my parents favorite way to
watch me work but i've not done a play
since i was
22. so like 20 20 almost 25 years ago
um i struggle with i i
right when i switched kind of to stand
up comedy i had a play that i wrote and
it was just me and one other person and
i i started going crazy it was it was my
first like month long run eight shows a
week yeah and i
i
wanted to
do new things so badly i got bored
i can't people who do god people who do
you know i've been phantom of the opera
for 15 years i don't know yeah i can't
imagine i'd rather be broke
that is that is tough
yeah you hope that maybe you can find
something in there it might not be every
night but maybe you know during the week
you're like oh there was a couple of
times where i tried this it was working
or i'm gonna use that tomorrow night and
stuff but i can understand the
repetition what i always feel like late
night talk show hosts sure you know that
medium of
15 or 20 years of
monologue guest
second guest musical act say goodbye and
it just goes on and on that
feels really tough too it's tough and i
feel like especially comedians
you're it's just the quality goes down
because of course it does i mean you're
barely making you're getting there and
you're finding out your cues let alone
writing comedy right right so i don't
know it doesn't it seems like a
thankless
job yeah
i'm trying to get billy to watch the
larry sanders show which is my all-time
favorite tv show and uh
just to to watch
i mean i think schandling is a very
underrated actor like he's really great
at that role
but to watch him go from
you know
kind of
an interested engaged
you know he's not always excited but
sometimes excited talk show host to
getting threatened by the network and
threatened by jon stewart and threatened
you know annoyed by his
like hank and and stuff like that and
then to watch him just kind of crumble
you know and just get to a point where
he's like
show's over and then who am i when the
show's yeah you know it's a brilliant he
loves jackson gary schandling if you
watch all the documentaries i think
because he struggled with it more than
comedy he had like a a real respect for
acting as opposed to like someone like
seinfeld who really seemed to have a
real resentment for the the entire art
form in general seinfeld is an
unbelievable stand-up comic in fact i've
been looking into he's doing it he's
doing a nationwide tour and i've been
looking into when he comes to l.a
because i want to get tickets and see
him in l.a maybe billy you can be my
date if i get us a couple of tickets
that would be fun right now cool yes why
not but
yeah jerry seinfeld can't really act but
shandling i think is excellent yeah uh
him rick torn and jeffrey tambour
amazing incredible
um so how how did it all start for you
then jean marco if you
you're saying that you were a theater
kid i mean out in new york yeah i went
to college from musical theater
and then i
then they kind of beat the joy out of i
don't think i was a singer
i don't i really i've only been booked
to sing these days at my grandparents
funerals
so it's it's that's been only full of
times yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a
bummer
it's it's i'm a good reminder there's
things worse limited run
it's uh
so i loved i used to love musical
theater and then i moved to philly i was
in like a meisner-based acting company
cult
um it really had the whole whenever i
see a cult documentary i see the whole
trajectory of this acting company
from you know worship of the leader
leader starts to have flaws crumbles
half the company loves her half the
company's rebelling chaos and then what
happened to this voice box so meisner
was a big smoker and i i believe it was
it was cancer the
and so the only real video of him
teaching there's like eight hours out
there
they removed his voice box so he's
teaching he's burping essentially that's
how he's he's burping every word he does
and he's still smoking
while he's doing all this i watched that
during covid one of one of my things
during covid was there was this it was
something like a 12-hour lecture class
with meisner and he had a whole bunch of
students that he takes them through some
exercises
and i was like oh my god i don't know if
i can watch this but
he he does ask really interesting
questions and obviously he's like
revered by his students you know yeah
he's uh he was he was the guy i was into
the most my uncle actually studied with
him as a teacher
and i think there was like he saw kind
of the darker side of it i guess meister
had like some kind of island he brought
some of the male students he preferred
okay just
just for some extra acting exercises oh
god well let's bring it back let's bring
it back
let's bring it back
uh but i was i was a big monster guy
he's great he's great sometimes you get
a lot of like
i don't know how deep in the weeds of
acting we go here but but you know
it can be a lot of i liked it because i
like to yell and a lot of those meisner
exercises just addressing each other's
behavior ends with like you're pissed
i'm pissed you're pissed i'm pissed yeah
and then every scene becomes
just a fight there's a few moments in
that course where he has like a duologue
going on
and he'll
they'll be in the middle of talking
and then he'll stop them and he'll go
say it again and the guy will say
whatever i love you no
again there you go i love you no again
he'll try and get the guy to say it like
20 or 30 times yeah and i guess he's
trying to
whatever stop the guy acting and just
kind of say the thing or maybe say it
simply or something but there's there's
a few occasions where you can see the
actors just turning around going
i've said it 35 times what are you
looking for he's like again again again
like jesus it's one of those things with
those older acting teachers sometimes i
can't tell
it's like am i learning a great acting
technique or
have i put this person on such a
pedestal and they're old and in this
case they have this voice that they make
you emotional like i i did a math class
with larry moss he's he's still around
he's still teaching it's one of those
things where he's just like an older guy
he's filling in for my grandpa or my
father or something but eventually they
like do that kind of stuff and then you
break down crying and you're like wow i
learned yeah and then you're like oh no
when i'm on set i need an older man
around here
to tell me to repeat the line 30 times
and then when i get my like one line on
blue bloods i'm like okay we don't have
that time right yeah yeah yeah
what about you bills when you were at
college who were the practitioners that
you guys lent to us i mean obviously
stanislavski seems to be standard right
but was there anyone else
nah i i i never really bought into all
the method stuff you know picking a
method i think
you know it's
for me it was always just trying to find
some truth and and
you know the stanzlafsky thing the only
thing that really stuck with me was i
think he did a famous sort of exercise
where he hides her
something and they have to go and find
it and and it was just that thing of
like
if you have to find something just
actually look for it you don't
act that you're looking for something
just look for something yeah yeah and
you know that the the simplicity of
that sort of thing is is really
kind of what i was more interested than
i never really liked
the idea of you know a method i i am now
following this person's yeah and as a as
you were saying gian marco that it's it
starts to feel like a cult you know yeah
yeah and i think in in it not just an
acting bit and
spirituality or religion as well i think
if it all gets narrowed down to what one
person says then you're basically then
trying to
live the life that they lived that got
them to that place but you've lived a
different life so
you're not going to be in the same place
so you have to kind of
you know grab what you can take but i do
i'm not one for saying oh i do this
method no neither you know
taking bits and pieces seems to be the
way there's a there's a a thing that i i
seem to use
from stanislavski quite a bit which i i
think was called the imaginary if
where
if the scene were to end what would that
person do i do think about that quite a
bit with my work so
you know whatever if i've had an
argument with
my wife in a scene and it ends in a
crescendo of her saying i'm going out
and she slams the door and the scene
ends i do quite often think okay
so what would my character now do
because if we see him in an hour what
has he done in that hour did he did he
meditate and now he's calm yeah or did
he drink three cups of coffee and when
we see him later on he's anxious and
annoyed so i think i do cherry pick that
little thing from stanislavski um but
also the brechtian stuff slightly
confused me because obviously
brecht is all about
this is a play these are performers
these are actors yeah yeah you can't do
that in tv and film because you can't
suddenly i mean sometimes you can break
the fourth wall but very often they want
you to be that person you can't be like
hey here's a cameraman here's a gaffer
he's a lighting guy
i like that an actor trying to be
brechtian on your film's side right
right i i should we should drink that
that'd be great i mean mike myers did it
in wayne's world right there's some
brechtian stuff in wayne's yeah he'll
chat and he'll be like here's a moment
of product placement here's the camera
my camera guy eating a slice of pizza
that's totally brechtian yeah whether he
knew that yeah breaking the fourth wall
you know you know i i think all these
techniques i think ultimately they're
supposed to be discarded i i left kind
of eisner and then i went full strasberg
and i was into that
that was all the emotional stuff right i
think that's because i struggled with
that the most that i was like i think
the thing you struggle with the most
same with gary shanley that's why he
loved acting where you're like this is
it the thing i can't do that's what i'm
most fascinated by
what's better than finding quality
candidates finding them instantly for a
powerful hiring partner you need indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place don't spend hours on multiple
job sites looking for candidates with
the right skills when you can do it all
with indeed find top talent with indeed
suite of powerful hiring tools like the
indeed instant match assessments and
virtual interviews oh i love that about
indeed they make everything so easy it's
all in one place because there are
things like instant match candidates you
invite to apply through instant match
are three times more likely to apply to
your job than candidates who only see it
in a search that's according to us
indeed data with instant match as soon
as you sponsor a post you get a shot
list of quality candidates whose resumes
on indeed match your job description and
you can invite them to apply right away
indeed does all the hard work for you
sponsor a job and boom instant match
shows you candidates whose resumes on
indeed fit your job description
immediately after you post with instant
match you can start hiring fast it's
true indeed knows that when you're doing
everything for your company you can't
afford to overspend on hiring visit
indeed.com to start hiring now just go
to indeed.com
indeed.com onion terms and conditions
apply cost per application pricing not
available for everyone need to hire you
need indeed
billy what i sometimes get a little bit
nervous when i'm online buying things
and as we know nowadays you tend to do
most of your shopping online yeah we're
not going to stores anymore so you're
giving all of your bank details
sensitive information sometimes makes me
feel a little bit nervous between my
family and my business life i've got
enough to worry about i need the peace
of mind of identity protection but how
do i do that and what protection do i
need how do i know well what you've got
to do is check out allstate identity
protection the best of identity
protection from a brand that you can
trust so much of life is logging into
our digital lives that's why allstate
developed an identity protection product
that protects your digital life just
like they do your physical life
with all state identity protection
they'll reimburse up to a million
dollars for out-of-pocket expenses lost
wages and legal fees they'll also cover
money stolen from your bank account
401ks hses and tax returns at allstate
they've been protecting the things
people love for over 90 years not only
will they monitor to help keep you safe
but should identity theft occur their
us-based customer service identity
specialist provide expert support 24 7
365 with an industry-leading 98
satisfaction score nice got a big or
growing family you can enroll your
entire household under one family plan
that spouse kids parents in-laws all for
a flat rate that's less than you would
pay for two individual plans and without
the typical age or residency
restrictions of where they live think
the identity protection your bank
provides is enough huh think again the
reality is that most financial
institutions act only after fraud occurs
rather than preventing it having
comprehensive monitoring and coverage
from aip will help stop identity thieves
in their tracks before any major damage
is done hey tom what i love about
allstate identity protection is how easy
it is to sign up i went online thinking
okay here we go this is going to take a
minute or two it's so fast and then
you're protected online is a great
feeling yeah i love that simplification
so when you think identity protection
think allstate identity protection to
find out if your employer offers
allstate identity protection head to
aip.com one last time that's aip.com
it sounds like you got
you know quite deeply into kind of
methods of acting and
you know looked at it very closely so
how do you jump from that to
stand-up or was stand-up always in the
background i it wasn't always in the
background i think i was like i was
uh comedic
um i certainly of my generation in
america we
really grew up in high school and uh
dave chappelle and dane cook were like
the stars
um dave chapel especially and then
i don't know you know i think i ended up
writing a play kind of as a vehicle for
myself and the play just had a lot of
me talking to the audience a lot a lot
of direct addresses and
i noticed
from the feedback that people were
raving about those parts and less about
the scenes
and
i i just eventually had a friend who who
saw the play and was like took me out to
lunch and very seriously was like you
should focus on this
and it's just a different life i was
kind of a homebody
and to be a stand-up
you you are giving up your nights and i
think i knew
what it was going to be if i was going
to really be a stand-up we're talking
at least in the beginning every single
night out doing spots three four five
spots a night if you're really digging
in there
and uh i was very scared but
once i started i got really hooked i
think i need constant feedback
emotionally i like if i'm writing
something i i'm always like can you look
at this key looks like you and with
stand up that's what the whole show is i
get immediate feedback about a new line
and oh that works and oh that didn't
work and i i feel very much in the
you feel very much in the throes of the
creative process
and you get the rewards immediately and
i think
real stand-ups get addicted to that
feeling
where i can go somewhere and try
something new and know that night if i'm
onto something or not
and once you're hooked into that
everything else feels like the idea of
writing a novel sounds insane to me to
write
something this massive and wait yeah and
i think you
you'd write a couple of pages and send
it to someone and yeah we stand up like
write a sentence and essentially find
out if it's good or not
yeah so yeah i think a lot of what
stand-up is
it's it's partly about do you love the
art form but it's partly like
emotionally what is your feedback loop
system
and uh if i do acting now if i do
something more dramatic i miss i miss
being able to know did that kill did
that crush
did someone cry
but that's why and once i was in
i was in
and so was that did that start in new
york started in new york so like a lot a
lot of people start in smaller scenes
and it's kind of a
when you start in a smaller scene you
you can become the king of or queen of
that scene very quickly maybe you could
be the queen yeah yeah yes you can open
for big acts that are coming by new york
you're automatically with some of the
best of the best there's some great
stand-ups out in la but la is uh at
least to new yorkers will say it's where
comedy kind of goes to die
new york's a little edgy right it's just
and it and it probably leans into that
stand-up comedy
vibe a little easier there's just a
little bit more of an edge on the street
a bit of a jump yeah that's part of it
but part of it is just
we're not dealing with we're not taking
generals during the day you do you do a
show here in l.a there's industry in the
showroom new york that's kind of that's
not around very much anymore so you're
there to do stand-up and there's a lot
in la that you know i think there's a
lot of big names out here and and you
start getting busy and stand-up becomes
secondary and the moment the stand-up
becomes secondary you can feel it you
can feel it in the specials and there's
it's so rare for stand-up comedians to
find success
and stay sharp i think
it's same with music or bands or anyone
who becomes successful but stand-up
takes time you cannot speed it along
yeah the george carlins of the world
stand up was always the priority people
like john mullaney shockingly has
maintained incredible
uh skill and obviously just must spend
time on it
so that's what happens and that's that's
kind of the reputation of folks that go
to la for the most part
let me create a little fictional
construct here and see
see if you can answer this question i'll
put you on the spot a little bit please
let's say
you're
in a stand-up club in new york
getting ready to go on
and some guy
comes in
never done stand-up before and they're
going to go on for the first time and
they come up to you and they say this is
my first time doing stand-up
what three pieces of advice would you
give me
to do or to not it's like a nightmare
situation i'm like oh god you let him in
the green room why how did he get on the
show why am i on this show
only there's only the two of you in the
green room you're fine you're a pro
you're like look man i've been doing
this for years it's a walk in the park
and they desperately say it's my first
ever show please just tell me what are
the three golden rules of what i should
or shouldn't be doing as a standard well
the one thing i'll say is that i think
because stand-up comics make it seem
kind of improvisational
the the writing it's too late to give
them to be like well write well you need
to be writing a lot stand up i mean i'm
a writer stand up so i am writing all
the time but if that's gone and this
person's got whatever jokes they're
gonna do
i think there is that that horribly
generic advice of having fun i believe
that unless i'm enjoying it
in some capacity
the crowd will not enjoy it too and that
doesn't necessarily mean smile and laugh
around but you have to be enjoying it
right there so that'd be number one
number two would be like
you have to take in the audience they're
your scene partner for lack of a better
word you're not going to let them have
you hopefully they won't if any lines
but you've got to like
take in the space
that that you are in and see what's
reacting i if it's a tough show i will
find the people who are digging it and i
will feed off their energy or i'll find
the people that don't dig it and i'll
try to really get them and find
excitement in that process
so
be happy
have fun
there's there's take in the room taking
the people
hmm and then that writing would be the
third one
right
go look at the material in the couple
minutes you have left before you go on
and then don't follow me
that's what i'd say most of all let me
go before you so i can go home
but we have a lot of that i mean
we have a lot of like uh fantasy
football
people will do their leagues and the
loser has to do
stand-up comedy wow and they headline
the show because they bring 15 of their
friends and it really is degrading to
have your profession be kind of the the
punishment for losing a fantasy football
league no no one loses a fantasy
football league and then has to go play
willie lowman
uh for one night only on broadway right
right right so that's that's the
stand-up comedy is one of those things
where we really dabble in
i feel like the most disrespect
of of an art form we were very valued at
certain times and other times we are
treated
uh like like an animal act in a circus
do you feel that in in new york there is
a sort of that some comedians sort of
eat that up that they almost like that
like you know you're talking about the
la thing and you know you do it
you do a night in the right club at the
right time in l.a and you'll get you
know you'll have your special or oh
let's come in and talk about what movie
you're doing where is it feels like new
york comedians those guys they they
don't want that they they're like no i'm
going to this club where no one likes me
and i'm going to do half an hour here
you know for sure for sure i think you
there's there's those comedians out
there
they who knows maybe they got the pilot
their their tv show with their name on
it in the 90s and it didn't make it to
air
but but you see the comedians like david
tell who i don't think he performs in
places where he's hated but david tell
is considered one of the like greatest
comedians of all time and he's not doing
a lot of movies or tv shows he doesn't
have a face for movies
why isn't he but these guys are the best
you know they're yeah they're the best
as you see they've taken the time and
it's just like
everything just builds and builds you
know the the comedy is so
kind of well structured you know and
you're like
but it almost seems like
they're they're torturing themselves as
they do
yeah you have to you have to kind of
want the punishment or the reward of a
bit working feels so good you're willing
to deal with the rougher nights
but once you get into what would be
ideal for you what would what like
it feels to me like you enjoy writing it
and and and polishing it i say all the
time the best i feel is like when a new
bit
clicks in like it's great to perform and
do an hour of everything you know that
works
but it's not as thrilling as as being
able to test something new or fine-tune
something new and that night when it
goes it's in i did it it's done
so
i just like to be
on stage i've been starting to headline
so i think the ideal is just being able
to perform longer sets i'm tired new
york you have to hop around do eight
minutes here 15 here 10 here that's
exhausting i'd rather i'd much rather
just do an hour a night
or or you know a couple hours on the
weekend where i get to really explore
every show you
do sure stadiums feel not ideal for
again like go back to like a play you
you won't want to do a long day's
journey into the night in madison square
garden that's going to be weird sporting
arenas in stadiums yeah it's a big event
you know it's much bigger the feeling so
i think like you you do that if you can
get to that level but i think the real
joy is like a smaller space
50 100 150 people it's harder though the
more famous you get the more you're
known
people start laughing or cheering
and that's like chris rock notoriously
when he goes to the comedy cellar and
when they introduce him people go yeah
they lose their mind they lose their
minds well i'm sure a lot of people are
sat there going we love comedy we we
could easily have paid
two hundred dollars to see of course and
we're paying 25 to see chris rock yeah
so i'm sure they're stoked about that
and he's raised right now i went there
once and it was chappelle went up and
then brought chris rock on stage and
they just they just did their thing for
an hour and a half
and i just stand in the doorway watching
but once you get that big though it's
tough because like chris rock will take
down his energy and will really talk
he'll almost purposely like make the
audience cool because how else can you
test material yeah you can't test
material everyone's going crazy for you
and he's he's so famous
he can't go anywhere without that kind
of love or excitement
much more famous now probably right yeah
well i mean that slap i sold out his
tour oh yeah in a way yeah
um i'm assuming you've seen the jerry
seinfeld comedian of course because i
just did
just for laughs which was
what that was built around right of
course and uh orne adams was the
community
yeah
it's just a really interesting way to
deconstruct not only his act but also
what it means to be a stand-up because
you know at his core
as we were just talking about you know
obviously he had a hugely successful tv
show
but as an actor he's he's not
necessarily the most skilled it's him as
a stand-up comedian where he really
moves into his
power so to see him in that documentary
start the show saying okay i'm going to
completely destroy my act i have no act
and then you're going to watch me build
that act and the process of it and the
angst of it whilst also watching
ornie adams just losing his
marbles during that yeah it's one of my
favorite docs ever it's i feel like i
listened to a recent interview with orny
adams he was on wtf and have you have
you seen this this documentary
yeah yeah and and so ornie adams if
you've for those who haven't seen it
like he was
exploding on the scene and he was going
to just for laughs and i think signed
with like william morris as he's going
up there and everything's coming
together yeah he's on magazines and
newspapers blah blah blah but he's his
ego's out of control
and then apparently he kind of like
bombed his jfl sets so just for laughs
is like the place
where all the industry is watching you
and he just like had a bad set and
didn't know how to handle it yeah
and i heard i heard while he was on
stage not doing well he like
like talked to his agent from the stage
like can you believe they don't like me
and the agent was like if you ever do
this again
it's just like someone who
it just collapsed and and they're making
a documentary about him before reality
tv was big so i think people don't it
was at that time people didn't realize
that you could really make yourself look
like a monster or an idiot yeah and
especially with the editing make it look
even worse it's excruciating
my favorite moment in that entire dark
and i i actually have used this a few
times with with people
because it's just it's just a great way
to just have people maybe like check
themselves a little bit is
jerry's jerry seinfeld is at a comedy
store
waiting to go on
probably like waiting half an hour or so
to go on and he's in the bar having a
club soda or whatever
and then ornie adams shows up and he's
sweating and he's you know he's kind of
like he's you know rushed to get there
and jerry's like hey how's it going they
obviously know each other hey how's it
going honey and
he's like yeah yeah i'm good it's just
you know so frustrating i'm trying to do
this and couldn't do a set there and
then i raced across town i only got
eight minutes here and you know then
this is going on and i can't get this
person on the phone and i want to move
to la but i don't have time and
you know now i got to do this and i got
to wait and you know you're going to do
your set and have to wait general
seifel's kind of nodding along and he
lets him finish his thing and then jerry
says you have somewhere else that you
need to be
and then he's like uh what do you mean
he's like if if there's somewhere else
you need to be you should go do that
like yeah and what he's saying is you're
a stand-up comedian you're waiting in
the wings to do your set this is exactly
where you need to be this is your job
yeah and and you can see him kind of get
kind of bristle a little bit and i just
i just love how he called him out in a
gentle kind of playful way and i've had
moments like that with with actors on
set where they're moaning oh man
it's cold and weather and i don't like
the scene and lunch was rubbish and blah
blah i'm going to come in tomorrow and
the calls at 7 a.m and stuff and i'm
like you have somewhere else you need to
be yeah you dreamt about being an actor
when you were eight nine ten years old
you're a professional actor you're doing
a great tv show this is a fantastic role
for you
do you have anywhere else more important
than you need to be right now because if
you do go do it yeah and jerry jerry
seinfeld's have you run into jerry
seinfeld a couple times yeah so yeah
how's his energy because he seems very
kind of mellow about it he's mellow i
think it's just like
stand-up is stand-up
is
we all have there's hierarchies with all
the systems so jerry's not the type
we're not gonna sit down and have a
conversation yeah he's up there right
he's up there i did a show it was it was
at a place in new york called west side
comedy club and i was hosting a couple
years ago and jerry seinfeld went on
twitter 30 minutes before as he'll do
and it basically said uh doing a set
west side that's it and he tagged west
side comedy club here in la he tagged
the wrong place so westside in la had to
release a statement saying jerry
seinfeld is not coming here tonight
meanwhile i'm on stage hosting this show
that joe is about to go on and jerry
didn't even issue a full correction he
just tweeted in new york period
so as i'm hosting i think on the upper
west side uh uh people found out and all
of a sudden i'm hosting and like dozens
of yarmulkes and i'm jewish dozens of
yamakas start pouring in all the jews of
the upper west side start pouring into
the venue as i'm hosting
and they're so excited and so you know
jerry gets there i i once said every
time i every time i see jerry seinfeld
if i come into a comedy club and i see
jerry seinfeld on stage i go
i'll go wow i guess i'm gonna be uh
going up a couple hours late tonight
cause that's what it means and it very
quickly turns into listen again i count
your blessings i i get to see chappelle
and chris rock and seinfeld but the
moment you see those people you're like
oh boy i'm not going up till 1 30 a.m
tonight yeah let me text the girlfriend
yeah no no survivor tonight yeah that
man you'd like survivor oh i'm a new a
new survivor so vibra is my all-time
favorite tv show i it started over the
pandemic so i've seen like five seasons
the last two and then three or four oh
my god we could sit here for another
three hours i love survival i'm friends
with jeff probst
oh he's that's so cool he's a he's a
really wonderful guy he and his wife
lisa and you'd be good on that show
right you could do that kind of yeah
sure they've been trying to do a kind of
whatever i don't like this word
celebrity survivor for a long time
i mean
they've i mean it's been like 10 years
that they've been trying to do it and
jessica has been like if we put it
together would you do it and i'm like
dude you're a buddy
of course if if it was something helpful
i i would do it and there's a lot of
people in the public eye that are huge
survivors oh my god but unfortunately
and we're hoping to have jeff on the
podcast and i think i think we will at
some point unfortunately because we've
explored this as well he's like i think
it kind of breaks the show because if we
do a celebrity survivor show it's going
to be very hard then for people to tune
in and go well wait we wanted to see
this actor who we like and this singer
that we like and this you know musician
that we like we're not as interested in
seeing you know people who you know are
not in the public eye i think
i mean i'm gonna like go off a little
bit now i think it's an extraordinary
show because you have the construct of
the show which is like who is going to
be the sole survivor yeah and they base
it around
obstacle courses and brain teasers and
all this kind of stuff so the social
game but then you've also got
multiple games happening inside the game
because the social game throws a lot of
people off and then maybe have a love
connection or
two friends that betray each other and
ultimately
you all have to betray each other yeah
so you've got 20 people saying listen
i'm never going to betray you but to win
the game you have to betray 19 people
and then they have to vote and say we're
okay that that person betrayed us well
that's what's amazing is like sometimes
it'll be like you know you lied and it's
like well yeah that's the game but some
people they they lie in a way that
people respect that's what's interesting
some people lie in a way that people go
you know what i respect it and other
people line away where they go you're a
snake and i'm never voting for you yeah
yeah i don't know if i could deal with
and i feel like the earlier seasons
focus on this
just the eating of wild animals they in
like season one they caught a rat and i
i'm in new york i see rats all the time
and i remember seeing rats and every
time i saw them for a while i was like
could i yeah could i catch that giant
rat and eat and kill it and then eat it
and i'm like
this
i'm okay with stuff like that i struggle
with
heights i'm not great
and if you expose yourself to that thing
then obviously at some point in the show
they're gonna be like okay
you're gonna walk across a tightrope
that's you know 80 feet in the air and
you're gonna climb a ladder that's you
know goes up for like another 100 feet
just to see how you do
that that would kind of throw me off a
little bit all the other stuff is fine
jeff probst is pretty tight with boston
rob do you know who boston roberts
because i think jeff kind of feels like
boston rob is arguably the greatest
survivor player ever i probably think
he's he's definitely in the top three
and i've spent a little bit of time now
with boston rob with jeff
and he is a really adept
social
um what's the word not manipulator like
engineer do you mean he yeah he's a
lovely guy but in a social situation he
makes sure that everyone feels like
they've been seen and taken care of he
re
kind of connects with people if it's
been a little bit of time and there's
been times where i've thought man i can
understand how you would win survivor
everyone feels like they're seen by yeah
acknowledged and then he's like you want
that last piece of chicken they're like
oh
you won it and he's like yeah i'll take
it and then he just takes it and you're
like okay i get it i actually gave billy
my favorite ever season of survival and
you've watched a few seasons right bills
no i've never actually saw someone
i've i've watched a couple of episodes i
love it uh but yeah no i and and i i
need to apologize that you did give me
your favorite ever um
season over and i lost it he lost it oh
yeah
oh dvd we're talking about dvds right
now
it's fine
it's all on paramount plus now um it was
fans versus favorites have you seen that
no i haven't so if so so now you you're
not necessarily doing it in order right
yeah i jumped around did you do like
best seasons of survivor ranks type
thing i did yeah i have i have friends
who like i had a friend who like made
a document of where to start and they
talk about like they say the australia
survivor is tremendous it is great it's
and there's like a new zealand i mean
there's so many yeah it's so much if
there was ever another pandemic yeah
which probably yeah sure uh
i think i could consider like let's just
do it all yeah yeah let's just do it all
well check out my
my favorite one and a lot of people's
favorite ones seems to be uh fans versus
favorites so you've got favorite people
coming back yeah and then super fans
going up against them there's a really
interesting guy in that called rupert he
kind of looks like an old grizzled kind
of pirate from the from oh yeah yeah i
just watched he's going i just watched
the pirate season
they voted him off and he was amazed
he's a lovely guy and he has a really
fun season on that that's fun talking of
which it says in your bio that you
do a fantastic jeff goldblum impression
um yes
i got a couple uh i always got him what
it was jeff i'm sure you've met him he
he's so so
he's jewish you and you also slightly
look like him right which helps i i i
think a little more than slightly i try
to distance it now but if i you know
i think jeff
so like if you look at like the woody
allen type you know he has the stutter
and jeff somehow took the jewish stutter
and he
he
elongated it and somehow made it sexy
and uh it's pretty it's an incredible uh
contribution to the jewish culture i
love it he also he's quite an
accomplished jazz musician right is
there is a piano that he plays piano he
tap dances tap dances he does the show
i've never met him i played him i did i
was in this uh billy crystal movie was
like a snl type show and i did a jeff
goldblum impression on that show and i
was like god how do i get this back to
jeff yeah yeah just so i can play his
son and stuff i think i did meet him
once on at some show and that thing that
you do with his hands is is very
interesting jeff goldblum thing but what
it feels like to me with goldblum when i
watch him is
because he's so well versed in jazz as a
musician and he's aware that jazz
is an element of just keeping things
going you know keeping the piano going
keeping the instrument moving
kind of um
you know
waiting to see what the other players
are going to do and in the meantime just
keeping everything going it feels like
when he speaks that's what he's doing
he's just ah like you asked me a
question let me think here i'm going to
go here
so all those little notes that don't
really make sense
that's very good man
billy and dom eat the world
welcome once again to billions on eat
the world now
john marco
soresi was that would that be the
correct pronunciation would you say
crazy but cerressi is is so close
so reese's crazy like crazy
yeah yeah yeah oh i love it right so
that to me doesn't sound like a japanese
name you could correct me
you're right on would you be italian
italian but just a little my dad
exaggerated it my mom's my mom's jewish
but my dad my dad acted raised me as if
i were 100 italian
and then one day i i went to italy and i
said where's where's the family
and uh he had trouble
naming any they're they exist they exist
over the pandemic someone from sicily a
distant cousin reached out oh lovely to
talk about my my great grandpa luigi
who was like a manager for boxers
uh so
yes but more jewish or or even
even um jewish food you're governors
noodles
ramen ramen noodles well uh my my my
parents got divorced when i was uh uh
just a babe
and when you have a single dad
um one dish that is heavily relied on
is uh ramen and so for me
if i'm thinking about my culture it is a
culture of single fathers i went back
and forth but at my dad's this is what i
ate
every single day and this is part of my
my heritage in its own way and was it
like was it like this sort of top ramen
that is exactly what it was oh i love
talking exactly what it was
it is incredibly tasty isn't it
i mean
billy have a look on this have a look on
the back of that packet have a look at
how much sodium
this is where it's so tasty look how
much i think it's something like 40 or
maybe 50 of your daily sodium is in that
one thing
so let's have a look at how much sodium
is in this dom
sodium
there is
1590 milligrams which is 69
of your daily uh what you need
so a couple of packets of this
two of those a day that's too much yeah
yeah almost seventy percent of the salt
you should be eating is in that tiny
little packet which makes it super tasty
but
uh
top ramen it's hard to beat top ramen
the best what are you having billy are
you having top ramen are you having
something else because we're having
no because i i wanted to get top ramen
because yeah my son
when we my son was growing up he he
loved top ramen and but only if my wife
made it he said that she made it better
than me which is kind of weird because
there's not much to the making of it you
would think
so i got this one because i could just
throw some um
throw some uh
boiling water and then it's ready to go
but uh what have you guys got like a
fresh ramen which is
very very difficult to eat but thick
noodles very thick noodles this is
definitely thicker thicker than what you
got there
well you guys got like fancy is it like
expensive noodles
no i think it looks pretty nice but it's
actually tasty once you get hold of it
it's at a nice nice room temperature
just a little bit of warmth echoes of
warmth i'm assuming ramen has its own
kind of scene vibe in new york city
right it's kind of a go-to thing yeah
does it feel like you get some authentic
kind of late night after the comedy club
that's the perfect meal to have
it's super yummy and i think when you
eat it you're supposed to suck in some
oxygen
why watch a lot of like yeah so anime
and manga i i read manga and watch anime
and like and all the anime all the
characters they really they bring it up
they're slurping it it's an aggressive
eat
and i do like that i feel like in
america
you're not supposed to sip from the bowl
i still sip from the bowl yeah i like
that too you know you you need the
oxygen you need this oh really lovely
lovely
like a true professional i've been
through and it tastes better it does
taste better because you've auctioned it
i've been threatening
with myself to watch this animated film
on hbo for a few nights now i've still
got still not got around to it it's
called bella did you see this thing no
i think billy you'd like this too
watch the trailer
it's about a girl
who
when she
kind of gets herself into the virtual
reality
metaverse her
superpower if you will
is her ability to sing she has an
angelic voice that like completely
throws people off and and has people do
things for her so um it's kind of a half
anime half
musical
which i remember thinking gosh billy'll
love this and supposedly the visual kind
of graphics and um
computer generated images are insane
i've been trying to watch it for the
last three nights and i keep getting
distracted playing video games instead
but i'm gonna watch it or
um i think you'd love it bills
hbo
that sounds good
bella i'll watch that sean marco oh geez
just lost my um
headphones do you still sing
it sounds like the the musical theater
world has destroyed your love
i love it in its own way i i i sing in
the in the shower and i was like i
probably do more vocal warm-ups than any
stand-up comedian in the world does
because it just feels like home
a lot of scales
i love it i hope someday
i can succeed enough as an actor that
they they put me in a musical even
though i'm not qualified anymore
that's a you know just like a mamma mia
10 by that point i would think
there's a couple musicals i would like i
think you'd be brilliant i would love to
do what would you do musical theater any
any favorites well as a kid growing up
obviously you do the
well
in britain at least it seems you do the
standard kind of oliver
wizard of oz
bugs him alone
um
which i did all those artful dodger tiny
tim
scarecrow
billy actually turned my head to
musicals as a grown-up i was very snobby
to be honest about it i was like ah
musicals not really my thing i'm into
more kind of you know
kind of realistic acting without
breaking into song and billy's like well
you're kind of missing out because
there's some incredibly emotional
things to watch out there yeah and
billy kind of kept pushing me and
pushing me and pushing me to go see the
miserable which i did in london
and i was like oh my god i didn't
realize how much it was just now and
since then i've seen you know matilda
and billy's in new york he just saw a
book of mormon and you've seen hamilton
tonight bills book of mormon was
fantastic so good i have to i have to
applaud the um
cast it was as
one of the best casts i've ever seen
on stage there wasn't a there wasn't a
weak link they were absolutely amazing
and the energy and
it was just
i was
very very impressed those guys are
geniuses have you seen the south park
movie way way back a long time ago the
bigger longer uncut thing yeah the one
which was a musical yeah and stephen
sondheim wrote them and said
stevenson wrote them said this is the
best musical of the year wow never i
mean they they really respect uh the
craft they love musicals they're
astounding yeah they're astounded very
very funny and then you're off to see
hamilton tonight bills which has one of
my
favorite emotional songs in it um
is it called uptown where they move
remember they move up town his after his
have you seen hamilton before bill
no no no oh really i'm looking forward
to it oh it's good it's quiet uptown
right
so
yeah well you tell me tonight but yeah
there's a there's a song in it called
it's quiet uptown my god incredible well
i'm going to read
bill do you want to read this first
blurb about ramen so that we can see if
we can uh that was i mean people
interested as uh as is um
derek
for um our johnny he's giving us quite a
lot
um but i'm not sure if any of it makes
much sense but let's let's try the first
paragraph it's all right
the origins of modern ramen
the first chinese noodles served in
japan weren't called ramen at all they
were known as sheena soba sheena is an
archaic japanese word for china and soba
was a catch-all term for any noodles
found in japan at the time
though it usually referred to buckwheat
noodles because of its offensive
connotations the word sheena eventually
fell out of use and was eventually
replaced by
ramen which likely came about from the
japanese pronunciation of the chinese
term
liamen
the word liamen comes from la which
means pooled and mian which means
noodles pilled noodles wonderful
well i thought that was very very good
and then i'm just racing through some of
this stuff now
um
says rahman really became mainstream
in 1958 courtesy of momofuku andu
inspired by his decade-old memories the
makeshift of of a makeshift ramen stand
he believed the cheap working-class meal
was a perfect fit for japanese pantries
it's kind of become
for me at least one of the things that i
have as a little bit of an emergency
thing in my in my cupboards do you know
what i mean
because if worse comes to worse and you
need that midnight snack or you've you
know you've you've forgotten to go get
eggs or something you're like oh i've
got nothing in the house there's always
a few packets of ramen in the back there
you think oh just quickly that's in the
bomb shelter for sure it lasts forever
i've moved where i've moved like a
second time and i'm like i'm moving this
ramen to a third location because i've
just had it forever wow just as a backup
yeah that's great so let's have a look
at like this packet that i've got just
now is okay until the 10th of june 2023.
yeah that's that's that's all right it
could go further than that i think it
could go further than that as well as i
mean it's a dehydrated noodle right so
what there's nothing that's going to go
well we don't know how long that's been
sitting in the cvs
it could have been there that could have
been there since you know since the war
there's like a there's a picture of
mason on the front there's we like to
give it scores and then how we do the
scores here is we give it out of them 10
and you're allowed decimal points and
the first thing we score on is taste let
me get a little bit more so um
first things first
what is the taste score out of ten well
billy marco i think you should go yeah
let's have john marco go first but billy
can i just ask what is the actual
flavor of that ramen pot that you're
eating because i think ours was just a
veggie ramen chili don that's a sweet
chili mine is a sweet chili style
stir-fry
it's um on the hot scale it's only got
one pepper
not that hot though yeah yeah no um um
flavor
ten uh
well the first thing i say was delicious
i was thankful for the meal
uh it was it was it was kind of the base
like this is the ramen you want to add
some stuff to it yeah a bit of spice
yeah so it definitely it had it had the
the ramen base but uh definitely not i
like a little sting
i like a couple peppers on there okay i
like to have a ramen yeah you want a few
pizzas yeah i like around meal that like
it would be tough to continue the
podcast as i was eating it
that i was in so much paper yeah do you
do you add stuff like that momofuku that
chili said you put some chilies chili's
in there i'll add an egg i love an egg
lovely uh yes thickened eggs
yeah leaks into the sauce a little bit i
mean when i eat cup of noodles as a kid
i would just douse it in tabasco sauce
it was the spiciest meal and i would be
crying by the end yeah i like my ramen
sometimes to make me sweat yeah um
sweaty ramen sweaty so this wasn't a
sweaty ramen so maybe you'd dock a few
points for that yeah it would dock a few
points but it definitely felt like this
would be a good starting place so out of
10 and you can give decimal points if
you want yeah i'll give it i'll give it
a i'll give it a 7.2 i'll go 7.2 wow
that's probably yeah what about you
bills i mean yours is different from
ours so
yeah well if we're if we're if we're
scoring this one
like it's not it's not as good as my
usual ramen but i'm still going to give
it a
7.5
[Music]
very positive don't very positive that
william boyd um
yeah i'm about the same as you which i
might go i like i like it to be
i like there to be a
a combination of flavors
some dried onion maybe some spring onion
an egg a little bit more tofu some spice
it's a seven for me my my girlfriend
show out some corn and i do love corn
oh yeah corn is good you've seen that
one
clip i think it was on tick-tock which
billy's obsessed with about the little
kid whose favorite thing in the world is
corn no what does he say it's just so
cute i don't they seem to be at a fair
or something and this guy's obviously
hit upon
this great opportunity to talk to this
kid who is over the moon about corn and
the guy's like why'd you like corn and
the kid's like what's not to like you
put butter on it it's amazing it's super
tasty it's good for you it's healthy
it's my favorite thing ever you can put
it in your pocket he like puts it in his
pocket that's the real plus it's like
transport yeah that's simple i've had uh
i had some friends from australia when
they visited me in america they were
shocked
because they don't really do corn over
there oh right i don't think cause corn
you know it's it's uh i think it's
american yeah maize is huge over here
and they were they were like the fact
that it was served as a side on its own
shocked them
i'm saying to bill i've said this before
why is it called
corn on the cob and then loose corn is
called corn surely the way that it comes
oh natural should be called corn and
they should call the other stuff corn
off the cob corn off the cup sure that
should be because the the way that it
shows up in real life should be the base
level that should be corn yeah and then
you're like how are we serving the corn
tonight oh we're having corn off the cob
do you know what i mean oh sure it
should be weird to do it the other way
around but
anyway uh wait what was that what's our
second category bills
aesthetics or looks
how does it look to you is it is it you
know does it get the juices go on as
well we're saying robin's tough
ramen's tough to go
it's all just becomes a clump in there a
little bit so so in terms of
it's not the worst this is a good this
was a good bowl like in terms of uh for
a takeout bowl
but i you know i gotta i gotta give it
give it a
give it a five
yeah
when it's in that when it's in that
wooden bowl and you got that spoon then
i don't even really use the spoon but
just having that weird shaped spoon that
big yeah
that's a good feeling and like you said
if there's an egg in there and it's kind
of orangey and maybe not
fully cooked and it's kind of leaking
into the soup and then you've got spring
onions and all that kind of stuff color
the cool thing about the noodles here is
that they're kind of like a nice kind of
spinachy green and
i like it but yeah ramen
generally is not necessarily
the best presented meal i'm gonna give
it i'll be kind i'll give it a six
that's nice i and i also like i like to
do like pretend as if i'm gonna use
chopsticks and then after three bites go
no yeah i'm gonna just use a fork
bills how's yours i'll i'll i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it a a higher score
because i
i agree that it's not maybe not the
nicest looking thing but i think
when you look at it you you know it's
going to be
okay
this meal is going to be okay it could
be fantastic
but it's going to be okay
you know it's so reliable i'm going to
stay aesthetic
because it does get my juices going tom
i'm going to give it uh
eight oh william
it's one of my favorite versions no gay
billy is when his juices get
flowing exactly the next one which i
think i'm feeling as if it could score
quite high here is
how useful is
when it's in the cupboard
and you know maybe all you've got is
that an egg
a couple of chilies maybe you've got a
breast of chicken i don't know what's
you know but how useful
is ramen
in your life
i i gotta give that a 10.
especially when i think about the money
because it is cheap it's cheap it is i
think yeah for bang for your buck
nothing
nothing beats ramen yeah like it's
stupidly cheap
like you get you get a box of it for
like five bucks yeah like how do they
make money what is it me what is that
it's almost made of nothing isn't it
really and and like billy said
you can add
so many things to it and it can be it
can just be a side dish if you want you
can have your food yeah and then you can
serve it almost like a pasta or a rice
or you can have the ramen actually be
the whole meal and you just put a whole
bunch of veggies and meat in there and
probably one of the most perfect nuclear
fallout shelter things to have right
and if you stick extra water in it
you've made yourself a soup dog oh
exactly i like that you could put it in
a thing you can have it dry you can have
it wet
no dumb it's it's got to be high it's
got to be a high score and i'm going to
give it a 9.8 wow almost a perfect score
yeah i'm with you guys i'm in the same
place i'll i'll say um
i mean the liquidy thing my thing is
always like can you put it in your
pocket and take it to a football game
with it being liquid does you love corn
then that's why you like corn i like
corn oh yes
um
it's not quite as perfect for travel
although in a thermos it's amazing i'll
give it a nine i'll give it a nine
well i think that's goodness high scores
all around for your uh for your top
ramen wilson lovelace have you ever been
to japan john marco i'm dying to go i
have not
so the only thing that i will say in
terms of ramen in japan and then
obviously coming back here
is it almost spoils it here because the
ramen in japan is so good yeah they do
something whether it's with the water or
with the noodles and there's a lot of
places where you can you show up and
before you go into the restaurant
there's a kiosk and a kind of electronic
kiosk similar to something in in the
states you might get a
kind of fizzy soda out of or or a candy
bar and you click you know i want ramen
with extra noodles two eggs spring onion
blah blah blah then you walk into the
restaurant and you see a booth
and then a little slide opens
and then they push it through there's no
staff nothing like that i love it and
that ramen like when it went to do wild
things we had all these opportunities to
go to different places and every night
we'd just be like should we just go back
to that ramen place because it was
unbelievable so it almost
ruins it in japan because it's so good
so you need to be conscious of that yeah
but you should do a tour oh maybe the
three should get over there i'm working
i think they think we're getting yeah
big enough you could maybe do it in
japanese
sure i might take about one sure you
know quite a lot of work i think
it's tough stand up in other languages i
mean i know people who are bilingual and
still don't necessarily do language in
the other
their second language because it's it's
just hard
the the
the syntax is different so especially
like comedically i mean it's it's kind
of a dumb but obvious rule where like
the funny part of the twist is at the
end right and you have a you have a
language where you do the adjectives
after the noun or anything like that it
changes it yeah changes it well do you
know eddie is i'm sure you do right yeah
yeah does a show in i believe french
spanish russian arabic italian
i mean just that's just a genius
does have an element of genius to to
their personality but that is like you
said to to be funny but then also to
understand the construct of the language
to be able to be funny in a different
language not just to be understood but
to be funny that is extraordinary yeah
what a talent well john marco it's been
amazing to have you on is there anything
in particular really if you want to tell
people out there in terms of where they
can see you or what you're yeah uh well
find me online at joe marcos sorayze on
all the platforms if you want to see me
live that's where i post my tour dates
and all that jazz uh i have a podcast
called the downside
where i interview folks about uh we we
celebrate the negativity we we finally
you know we have people complain and
convict to use a jewish word so it's
just it's a it's us uh an opportunity
for people to come on and talk about the
things that get on their nerves oh yeah
oh and sometimes we have you know
particularly we just had someone who who
worked at a morgue and you know talked
about the downsides of which there are
many working at a more no there must be
uh uh oh yeah so it's it's a fun
uh if you if you like that kind of stuff
if you like to complain and [ __ ] and
moan come listen to that the downside
with the power comes crazy
i'll come on and i'll talk about
um
people having the clicky button on their
phone on that's the kind of stuff we
love
what is that about who is that click for
you know you're typing so you don't need
the click are you telling other people
that you're typing yeah my mum and dad
do it all the time so we're sat watching
something i just hear my mom and dad in
the back good going
who's that for sure
makes
i actually think that the phone itself
should just take it out it shouldn't be
an option anymore
i don't understand why we need it i
think that it just it's it's nostalgia
it's nostalgia and i see the ways
that
the now that i'm getting older and and
the the things that i do miss like for
example i think about all the time how
menus have kind of gone away
and i miss menus but i feel like if you
were to explain it to someone who never
had menus they'd go you want a dirty
piece of paper that's been passed around
and i'm like yes
and for your parents that's it's that's
that sound maybe it's that and one of
the things uh i hate is uh people who
leave before the end of a conversation
but i'm going to be that guy because i'm
off to see hamilton yes brilliant and
i'll mess material have a fantastic time
say hello to the family bills we'll see
you sometime soon hey guys we'll see you
next week thanks for tuning in obviously
you know how to get hold of us um on our
youtube channel and you can send
messages on our voicemail that's uh the
french bunny that's speak pipe forward
slash oh i've got it wrong what is it
john
speak pipe dot com forward slash the
friendship onion did they hear that john
or do i need to repeat it they
absolutely heard it um please rate
review and subscribe to us uh let us
know anything in particular that you
want us to eat or maybe a guest that you
think would be great on the show we'd
love to hear from you we're gonna do a
fan art special episode
so if you send in all your fan art now
for the next few weeks
we're gonna pool it all together and
billy and i will sit around and we'll
open up the fan art and we'll hopefully
put it on some of this negative space
that we have behind us here i can't do
the hand thing because it's backwards
here above me here and above john
marco's head we'll put all of your work
here so send us in your fan art we'll
put the address of the studio in the
show notes and we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
on my pearl